[Música]
en Primera Plana
ahí da Palau
Bienvenidos a todos en Primera Plana un
programa de radio Francia internacional
y France 24 esta semana con la atención
puesta en Ucrania cuando se cumple un
año de la invasión rusa más
concretamente hoy nos interesamos por la
destrucción del patrimonio hasta la
fecha se han destrozado dañado 240
sitios culturales nos acompañan hoy
Ernesto otone subdirector general de
cultura de la UNESCO bienvenido
También estamos con David gormezano que
es periodista en France 24 y que acaba
de regresar de Ucrania bienvenido y con
Delia arrunategui que es periodista
independiente especializada en economía
Muchas gracias Delia Gracias la
destrucción del patrimonio en Ucrania
consecuencia del conflicto o estrategia
hoy en Primera Plana
qué estupidez la guerra decía el poeta
francés
hablando de la Segunda Guerra Mundial
pues la estupidez de los hombres y la
guerra volvieron a Europa el 24 de
febrero de 2022 después de semanas de
amenazas lo impensable se produjo Rusia
atacó Ucrania un año después lo que
Moscú calificó de operación especial que
debía resolverse en poco tiempo continúa
el balance es aterrador de decenas de
miles de Muertos millones de refugiados
y desplazados internos ciudades
destruidas y una economía muy golpeada y
sobre todo muy pocas perspectivas de que
este conflicto se resuelva a corto plazo
hemos recuperado algunas portadas el
francés Liberación titulada lo
impensable con la foto de la explosión
de un misil en kiev también el francés
le ha ido titulaba
en esas portadas Érase una vez Mario
Paul con el dibujo de una playa llena de
bañistas Disfrutando del Sol y el agua
antes de la guerra loves publica una
edición doble la loca historia del
imperio ruso de Iván el Terrible a
Vladimir Putin y como les avanzábamos en
medio del horror de la guerra con la
pérdida de Vidas humanas está también la
destrucción del patrimonio el diario
español el mundo publicaba en noviembre
pasado el gran saqueo de gersón
afirmando que antes de retirarse de esa
ciudad los soldados rusos arrasaron con
el patrimonio robaron restos del General
potenkin 10.000 piezas de arte de los
museos bibliotecas y hasta incluso
animales del Zoo
240 sitios culturales de Ucrania han
sido parcial o totalmente
destruidos desde el comienzo de esta
invasión rusa en Ucrania alrededor del
2022 Ernesto ottone ustedes desde la
UNESCO monitorea no esos daños del
patrimonio cuéntenos que se ha destruido
en Ucrania
bueno
la autoridad de ucraniana van a decir
una cifra distinta la autoridad es rusa
van a decir otra cifra lo que nosotros
hacemos es a través de imagen satelital
verificar los daños de sitios culturales
sean sitios del patrimonio mundial
inscrito monumento en la lista
indicativa u otro monumento que están en
las listas nacionales
y lo verificamos para chequear que
efectivamente a través de unos SAT
unidad que son la agencia especializada
de Naciones Unidas y monitoreo satelital
no para el patrimonio Generalmente esto
es totalmente nuevo nosotros lo hacíamos
periódicamente lo hicimos una Afganistán
en Mali en algunos conflictos en yemen
en Siria pero hoy en día se armó una
nueva plataforma que lo que hace
monitorear diariamente la destrucción y
la revisión de imágenes de monumentos
culturales sean religiosos sean
monumentos sean
histórico
que están en registrados como tales y
efectivamente lo que tenemos al día de
hoy un año después de la intervención y
de la guerra Son 240 edificios
verificados destruidos como lo dijo
parcial o totalmente
eso significa que
hoy en día con la autoridad ucraniana
cuando estamos haciendo la visión de más
largo aliento que es la reconstrucción
una vez que el conflicto termine
significa que ya se está preparando y
cuantificando
financieramente pero también a nivel de
Cuál es la ayuda necesaria para
restaurar esos edificios Y eso inmueble
comentaba antes de iniciar el programa
que está en contacto
diariamente no con las autoridades
ucranianas con el Ministerio de cultura
Que qué les dicen el Ministerio cultura
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores que
son los dos que monitorean estos temas
Ellos están muy preocupado está muy
preocupado hace dos meses además por el
invierno porque el problema es que por
ejemplo un museo que es destruido
parcialmente significa que las
colecciones quedan al intemperie no hay
electricidad por lo tanto las
necesidades básicas en este momento es
el mantenimiento de su espacio con
condiciones mínimas adecuadas entonces
son generadores biogeneradores
todo el tema de los monumentos de cómo
se resguardan y finalmente está el
famoso escudo azul hablaremos enseguida
de ese escudo azul pero primero David
gormezano que acaba de regresar de
Ucrania tras un año de guerra cómo están
los los ánimos de la población dónde ha
estado Exactamente Bueno la población en
Ucrania está con una determinación
tremenda de de ganar esa guerra porque
para para los ucranianos no hay otra
opción
y en un año el ánimo todavía está muy
fuerte se siente de vez en cuando un
cansancio un agotamiento porque
hay muchas familias que están separadas
hay en muchos mucha gente tiene amigos
familiares que está en las zonas de
combates en el en el este en el en el
sur del país y eso genera una una
ansiedad muy fuerte
desde octubre hay poca electricidad del
país hay hay cortes de de electricidad
en toda Ucrania pero mucho mucho
ucranianos dicen que esto que se adaptan
a la situación que hay muchos
generadores que llegaron al país
y eso no es el es no es el tema
principal que que Putin puede
seguir atacando y bombardear la
infraestructura energética del país esto
no va a cambiar el ánimo
la gente se organiza la gente que
resistir a la agresión rusa En qué
ciudad esa ha estado en este último
viaje a Ucrania y ha visto un poco
cambios en las ciudades en cuanto al
patrimonio cultural no sé si destrucción
pero tal vez sí que se han sacado
estatuas no en este caso
estatuas rusas sacadas por las
autoridades ucranianas El último viaje
fue a Odessa y yo no conocía Odessa Así
que descubrí esa ciudad que
realmente maravillosa que es el centro
histórico es muy impresionante la la
historia de de Odessa es fascinante y
hemos hablado con el con los compañeros
de Francia 24 con el alcalde de la
ciudad que tiene una historia muy
particular y también Vimos a la estatura
de Catarina dos La Grande imperatura de
de Lucía era un cajón de madera puesto
cerca del Museo de Bellas Artes de
Odessa y
el intento
Rusia Vladimir Putin se imaginaba
ganar la guerra muy rápidamente y que
hay una ciudad comodesa la gente
viera la ocupación rusa con como una
Liberación no que es lo que venden los
rusos no
y no está pasado eso
muy al contrario la la parte de la
población que hablaba ruso que que tiene
una cultura muy muy rusa
rechaza totalmente la voluntad de Rusia
de de conquerir el país y de
bombardearlo Delia ante la pérdida de
vidas y las bueno consecuencias
apremiantes no de la guerra proteger el
patrimonio en un terreno de guerra es
muy complicado lo comentaba antes
Ernesto Pero bueno es luego muy muy muy
difícil volverlo a recuperar no los
daños pueden ser muy costosos los daños
son muy costosos pero al mismo al mismo
tiempo es fundamental preservar en
primera en primera parte preservar lo
que es la el patrimonio nacional En este
caso de Ucrania porque es la parte de la
identidad del pueblo ucraniano por eso
es que es blanco de de saqueos de de
misiles de por parte rusa porque eso es
como un nexo entre lo que es el pasado y
el presente y es lo que construye parte
de la nación de la identidad nacional de
de un país por eso es fundamental
preservarlo y en todo caso a futuro si
aún así no se puede impedir la
destrucción
reconstruirlo porque es el nexo que
ayuda a vivir el presente pero también a
construir el futuro Ernesto entre las
medidas de que la UNESCO ha puesto en
marcha está justamente que el centro
histórico de diodesa ha sido declarado
patrimonio mundial en peligro Por qué
Odessa Y qué implica esta protección a
ver hay que saber que Ucrania tiene
tenía siete sitios incluidos en el
patrimonio mundial entre ellos está
crimea y esos complejos porque ya había
sido ocupado
en la reunión extraordinaria que hubo en
el mes de enero del comité del
patrimonio se inscribe se propone
por parte de la autoridad ucraniana de
inscribir o de esa en la lista del
patrimonio y en la lista en peligro del
patrimonio inmediatamente
Cuál es la idea es la protección de
Odessa la idea de la autoridad es que
hicieron un tiempo récord la sumisión
del
tema súper complejo porque tiene que
haber misiones acá si son misiones de
aspecto para poder asegurar que tenía lo
que se llama el valor universal y
efectivamente cualquier persona que haya
pisado el centro histórico de Odessa y
parte del puerto la parte más antigua se
habrá reconocer que una ciudad única en
la historia de decir por las
conjunciones de distintas culturas que
se fueron construyendo
en esta presentación vino el ministro
cultura el alcalde de Odessa y
efectivamente para ellos esto
significaba
una una protección mayor
para esta ciudad por qué porque
cualquiera de estas sitios que se
inscriben en la lista del patrimonio
tienen obligaciones por parte de de toda
la comunidad internacional es decir la
destrucción de cualquier sitio sea del
patrimonio a través de lo que se llama
la convención de la haya y su segundo
protocolo la 54 implica que una
destrucción de ese patrimonio puede
convertirse en crimen de guerra hoy en
día por eso es tan importante era
importante para para los ucranianos
Bueno hacemos una pequeña pausa y
enseguida volvemos para seguir hablando
de este tema
[Música]
Enlace del cono Sur a Norteamérica de
los Andes a Centroamérica una cita
semanal con los temas más representantes
de los países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
France 24
enlace en France 24 y Franz 24.com
sabe cómo identificarlas acompáñenos 24
vea como distinguir entre información y
contenido falso en las redes sociales
desinformando una herramienta para
verificar y contextualizar información
certificada todos los días en todas
nuestras emisiones
[Música]
Bueno pues seguimos en Primera Plana
hablando hoy de la destrucción del
patrimonio en Ucrania estamos en
nuestros estudios con Ernesto otone que
su director general de cultura de la
UNESCO con David gormezano periodista en
France 24 que acaba de regresar de
Ucrania y condelia a runategui que es
periodista independiente especializada
en economía Pero antes vamos a conectar
con nuestra corresponsal en Bruselas que
ha seguido la respuesta de la Unión
Europea y de la otan a la crisis
ucraniana Buenos días Esther Herrera
bienvenida
es un placer estar aquí Muchas gracias
Bueno concretamente qué ayuda ha
prometido la Unión Europea para la
reconstrucción posguerra en Ucrania de
momento no hay cifras concretas de
cuánto se va a donar para la
reconstrucción de Ucrania pero la Unión
Europea está ahora ha dado más de 60.000
millones de euros una parte 18.000
millones van directamente para hacer
frente a pagos mensuales más inmediatos
del país paralelamente ha donado unos
seis mil millones de euros para el envío
de armas un hito histórico en la Unión
Europea el pasado mayo en una
conferencia de donantes se llegó a los
39 mil millones de euros de los que
participa la Unión Europea un dinero que
se considera un Punto de partida para la
creación de un fondo fiduciario para la
Ucrania en la que se irá añadiendo poco
a poco dinero para una futura
reconstrucción por último la comisión
europea se está preparando para utilizar
una parte de los activos congelados del
Banco Central de Rusia aproximadamente
unos 300.000 millones de euros y también
utilizar una parte de los activos
congelados de oligarcas y también sus
bienes para la reconstrucción de Ucrania
una medida que aun así es muy
controvertida y que no convence a todos
los países El problema es plantea que se
planee financiar la reconstrucción con
activos congelados rusos por las
la comisión europea plantea varias
cuestiones recientemente propuso que se
puedan confiscar los bienes de los
oligarcas rusos si estos intentan
esquivar las sanciones y esto esquivar
las sanciones se convierta en delito
Pero toda hora Ahora mismo Está en manos
de los estados que tienen que aprobarlo
los gobiernos lo están negociando y de
momento no se ha hecho la otra opción es
utilizar los activos del Banco Central
de Rusia para emitir bonos y el dinero
que se genere de estos activos pueda
servir para la reconstrucción esto
permitiría que con un futuro final de la
guerra todo el dinero se pueda devolver
porque la legislación internacional así
lo obliga todo lo confiscado se debe
devolver siempre el objetivo según la
comisión europea Es que luego en un
futuro acuerdo de paz se acuerde también
la cuestión de la reconstrucción entre
las partes en la última ronda de
sanciones propuesta por la comisión
europea los estados miembros deberán
rastrear todos los activos y bienes de
oligarcas para saber cuánto dinero hay
exactamente congelado en la Unión
Europea que se calcula más o menos en el
caso de los oligarcas en unos 15.000
millones de euros aún así muchos países
tienen dudas porque no hay precedentes
legales de algo parecido y teme que
contravengan varias leyes
internacionales son estas dudas legales
que incomodan a varios países europeos
más aún cuando consideran que los
recaudado con esta confiscación de
bienes es una mínima parte en realidad
de lo que necesita Ucrania Muchas
gracias Esther Herrera desde Bruselas
Delia parece muy complicado articular
esta ayuda a partir de dinero congelado
por oligarca rusos hace falta más dinero
Aún así cómo se piensa la reconstrucción
cuando el fin de esta guerra parece a un
bastante lejano y con todas las
urgencias humanitarias que hay no parece
como que el patrimonio viene después por
el momento efectivamente hay urgencias
que tienen cierta relación Yo creo que
se se evocó con anterioridad que por
ejemplo para preservar las obras de
artes que hay que existen en un museo se
necesita cierto tipo de de temperaturas
si hay falta de Electricidad Por ejemplo
yo no se puede garantizar Entonces
cuando se habla de una reconstrucción se
habla de una reconstrucción primeramente
de las necesidades básicas para la
población es decir la necesidad
eléctrica de suministro de agua sobre
todo eléctrica porque También incluye la
calefacción todavía estamos en el
invierno europeo y es una necesidad
primaria hay que hacer la diferencia Yo
creo que el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron hace poco hace una semana dijo
que ni bien un territorio
reconquistado por Ucrania donde donde
estuvo el
ejército ruso tiene que comenzar la
reconstrucción pero definitivamente son
de la reconstrucción de los de las
necesidades básicas totalmente una vez
finalizado la guerra ya se hablará de la
reconstrucción del patrimonio el cual
también es fundamental para para la para
el para Ucrania lo comentábamos al
principio en una de las portadas los
rusos se llevaron los restos del General
potenkin cuando se retiraron de gersón
dijeron que se lo llevaban porque no
estaban a salvo bajo control ucraniano
sabemos que Putin David es un gran
admirador de potencia porque fue el
quien en el siglo XVIII conquistó
territorios del sur y fundó ciudades
comodesa gerson que los rusos se hayan
llevado las osamentas o los restos de
poten King es muy simbólico verdad no de
lo que está ocurriendo Sí sí totalmente
y
el ámbito cultural en Ucrania
no no está parado por la guerra
y en los museos en los teatros y los
artistas son muy activos en la guerra
aportan como pueden su
su contribución al esfuerzo de guerra y
me encontré en odesa con el director del
Museo de Bellas Artes
que organizó en las primeras semanas de
la guerra la salida de sus de las
colecciones del museo a un lugar seguro
y insisto En decir lo que pongo en este
lugar seguro Son obras de artistas
ucranianos pero rusos también porque lo
que no queremos es que
bandas de soldados incontrolados porque
hay
saquen obras de los museos para venderlo
en el mercado negro eso es una es una
preocupación muy fuerte de del ámbito en
el ámbito cultural en Ucrania al momento
y es un problema que parece ser que ya
se está produciendo cuando se observa el
caso ucraniano nos acordamos también de
cómo en otras guerras se destruyó el
patrimonio cultural tenemos por ejemplo
el caso de los budas Gigantes de
bamillar en Afganistán los talibán los
volaron por los Ai tenían más de 1500
años de antigüedad También tenemos otros
ejemplos como en tombuctúen Mali los
yihadistas destruyeron entre otros
manuscritos preislámicos de un gran
valor en Siria todos tenemos en mente la
ciudad histórica de Palmira
completamente arrasada por el Isis me
acuerdo del jefe de arqueología que se
quedó para proteger y que fue decapitado
la destrucción no solo la consecuencia
de
un conflicto la destrucción del
patrimonio es una estrategia en el
conflicto propio para borrar una parte
de la identidad Ernesto en los casos que
acabo de citar parece bastante Claro
pero en el caso de Ucrania es más
complejo porque Ucrania comparte una
historia con Rusia no absolutamente en
la situación que estamos viviendo de
destrucción del patrimonio o saqueo
tráfico ilícito que estamos viendo para
nosotros Incluso como organizaciones
distintos nosotros interveníamos en el
pasado y digo en el pasado cuando el
conflicto ya está terminado acá estamos
la mitad de conflicto que no se sabe en
qué momento o de qué modo va a terminar
por lo tanto cualquier acción que se
haga por ejemplo de reconstruir un museo
hoy sería absurdo porque no sabemos si
la reconstrucción en dos meses más va a
ser destruido Entonces por un lado eso
segundo todos los casos que tú citas
efectivamente tienen que ver con tema de
este mismo el ejemplo que se podría
asimilar es lo que pasó
la reconstrucción del puente de mostar
es decir hace 20 años en Europa pasamos
por un conflicto similar de países que
comparten historia común con diferencias
religiosas y con diferencias
conceptuales Pero tenemos ejemplo en
Europa en el en el pasado donde vivimos
conflictos así y después la
reconciliación y la reconstrucción es
muy larga eso hay que tenerlo en cuenta
no es que se termine la guerra todo el
mundo se saluda Y empezamos la lista y
empezamos a reconstruir
David
me gustaría que nos hablara una parte de
Ucrania donde se está produciendo una
desrusificación digamos
de del patrimonio cultural
efectivamente por
porque están en contra de esa invasión
no cosas que antes Bueno está tú así tal
que formaban parte de la vida y la
historia del patrimonio de una ciudad
ahora estaríamos casi más cerca digamos
de cuando se hacen caer la Estatua de
San José y de Bagdad no sé no sé cómo lo
ve hacer caer las estatuas es algo de
que pasa en Las Guerras no y
en Ucrania lo que es la Estatua de
Catarina 2 La que que focalizó mucha
mucha atención Pero ese proceso de de
rusificación es muy complejo empezó en
el 2014 con
con la cuando la
se fueron
bueno se separaron
y que fuerzas a favor de
Moscú ocuparon estos Y desde ese momento
hubo una serie de leyes para
para un cráneo
organizar el país y es un proceso muy
muy complejo porque hay una parte una
grande parte del país habla Ruso y
hablaba Ruso y ucraniano y ahora hubo
resistencias de parte de la población
que tiene mucho vínculo con Rusia en
Cruz familiares vinculo por el tema del
idioma de la cultura pero con la con la
guerra Total que empezó en febrero del
año pasado estas resistencias están
Están muy pocas ahora en Ucrania una
guerra por el territorio Pero también es
una guerra de identidad y de historia no
sé si alguien quiere opinar totalmente
estaba pensando lo mismo en este en este
caso se ve la importancia que tiene
tanto para Rusia como para Ucrania
cultura la identidad las estatuas es
tiene una simbología muy fuerte por eso
en una guerra uno de los blancos que
eligen es la destrucción de este de este
tipo de monumentos y estatuas porque lo
que se busca mermar es también la
identidad y el orgullo del pueblo que el
cual se quiere someter Ernesto no nos
queda mucho tiempo pero quería no quería
despedirme sin hablar de ese tráfico
ilícito de obras de arte Ya se está
produciendo se está produciendo lo que
nosotros Acabamos de terminar la semana
pasada es en los países fronterizos
específicamente en Polonia organizamos
con todos los agentes de aduanas de
policía y de museo directores más de 500
profesionales un trabajo de tres días de
capacitación para justamente ver cuáles
son la convención del 70 que contra el
tráfico ilícito nuestro sistema para
parar que ese tráfico pueda llegar a
otros países pues muchísimas gracias
a los tres Y muchísimas gracias a todos
ustedes por habernos acompañado ya saben
que también nos pueden seguir por
internet en rf y mundo.com y en France
24.com Hasta pronto amigos